toujours vivant et voici donc l'invité
des 5 dernières
minutes et cet invité c'est Nicolas
HULLOT bonjour merci de nous avoir
rejoint ici sur le plateau du Trésor
vous êtes de passage he en France entre
deux deux tournages on vous a venir
parce qu' évidemment c'est Kyoto une
question d'abord ça vous est venu d'où
cette cette passion pour l'écologie et
pour la défense de la planète de c'est
venu graduellement
une chose qui va vous paraître
surprenant c'est que j'ai réalisé chemin
faaisant qu'on vivait dans une planète
beaucoup plus petite qu'on
l'imaginait j'ai réalisé chemin faaisant
que l'humanité était devenue une quasi
force géologique et j'ai réalisé chemin
faaisant et sous l'expertise de
véritable scientifique que le sort de
l'homme n'était pas distinct de celui du
reste des êtres vivants et que le destin
de l'homme était à très court TER menacé
si nous nous entétions dans un certain
nombre de pratiqu donc voilà face à ces
évidences sous lesquelles nous croulons
mais que nous nions à travers vos
reportages aussi vos voyage à travers m
reportages et puis mon engagement
écologique et le fait que je travaille
avec un certain nombre de scientifiques
qui depuis des années cri un peu dans le
désert ses inquiétudes qui chemin
faisant sont devenus un début de réalité
et le temps que nous avons perdu dans
l'hésitation le scepticisme et
l'immobilisme rend la résolution de ces
équations particulièrement délicate et
Kyoto en est une bonne illustration
Kyoto vous m'aidez Kyoto qu'est-ce que
vous en dites hein ça fait 8 ans 141
pays surtout les pays industrialisés une
trentaine qui sont donc tenus par des
engagements de diminution des de
l'émission des gaz à effet de serre
c'est assez c'est pas assez c'est un
début c'est quoi alors d'abord on voit
que le cheminement de la raison est long
mais que au moins réjouissons-nous là
que une partie de la communauté
internationale vienne sur l'hôtel de la
raison et engage une dynamique parce que
la la grande vertu de Kyoto c'est
qu'elle a elle va inverser une tendance
on était dans une croissance
asymptotique des émissions de gaz à
effet de ser on commenc à freiner avec
les conséquences dramatiques que l'on
sait sur les perturbations climatiques
on va inverser cette tendance ça c'est
une bonne chose et on crée une dynamique
parce que on va obliger ceux qui ont
adhéré et qui ont ratifier Kyoto à
trouver à mobiliser leur ingéniosité
leur technologie pour atteindre ses
objectifs une fois ceci dit et se
réjouissant donc de cette date
historique par a qui disent c'est peu de
choses ça va être très cher ou c'est le
premier pas et Dieu sait qu'on était
nombreux à réclamer que au moins on
commence à emprunter le chemin et qu'on
fasse revenir à la ratification et là on
peut er l'action diplomatique de la
France la Russie sans la signature
desquelles Kyoto n'aurait pas pu être
ratifié donc c'est une bonne chose
maintenant Kyoto ça n'est pas un
aboutissement c'est un départ et quand
on voit la difficulté auquelle nous
entre autres la France mais l'Europe et
les pays occidentaux seront confrontter
pour tenir le engagements de Kyoto qui
ne représente qu'à peine 10 % de
l'objectif parce que l'objectif c'est de
ne plus agir sur lesffit de serre et
pour ne plus agir sur lesffit de serre
il faudrait selon les pays diviser par
deux ou par 4 le nos émissions Act plus
sévèrement ce qu'on fait et cetera vous
dites la France belleaction et ca on
sait que vous êtes proche de Jacques
Chirac on vous a vu en colère sur l'ire
de Canel on vous a vu et cetera vous
avez l'impression que la France fait
assez ou qu'elle se retranche derrière
son parc nucléaire en se disant bah moi
j'ai pas d'efforts à faire sont les
autres qui ont des efforts à faire mon
mon rôle et le devoir des des ONG c'est
d'être exigeant non pas parce que nous
sommes exigeants d'une manière chronique
parce que l'on sait trop pour s'être
intéressé aux conséquences des
changements climatiques desésordres
écologiques desésordres des ordres
sociaux desordes économiques que les
crises qui vont poindre leur nez dans le
courant du siècle vont être d'une telle
échelle que si on peut les épargner ou
les atténuer tout le monde s'en
trouvera on n' fait évidemment pas assez
bien entendu mais la France est assez
moteur en Europe elle a ses propres
incohérences et il est vrai que si elle
veut tenir les engagements réitéré par
le président avan-ier de diviser par 4
on va pas s'accommoder de petite mesure
parce un mot s'il faut dire un mot aux
gens qui nous écoutent aux jeunes
notamment qu'est-ce qui vous met en
colère aujourd'hui qu'est-ce qu'il faut
changer d'urgence là on a plus que 30
secondes il faut que tous
individuellement et collectivement on
prenne notre part de responsabilité moi
je me bats au niveau de la collectivité
il faut qu'individuellement on essaie de
regarder comment nous pouvons être des
consommateurs plus responsables et être
moins dépensi en terme d'énergie et
peser moins sur l'environnement il y a
des gestes simples que l'on peut faire
pour être plus raisonable on peut donner
une voix nous les consommateurs et N pas
que si nous faisons un effort
individuellement nous les ONG on se
charge de mettre en cohérence le
gouvernement merci beaucoup et on voyait
que justement si on gaffe au petit Gest
de la vie quotidienne à la télé qu'on
laisse env et cetera tout ça ça
représente je crois quasiment la moitié
des efforts qu'on doit faire d'après
queoto nous la France accumulé au fil de
l'année merci beaucoup d'être venu on
arrive à la fin de cette édition dans un
instant donc la météo Nathalie riwe 20h
David Pujadas juste après 100 minutes
pour convaincre avec Olivier mazerol qui
reçoit donc domin roskan et Hervé
guemard nous on se retrouve demain à 13h
bon après-midi sur France 2